>> Sean: IT LOOKS LIKE THE
REAL SPEAKER OF THE HOUSE,
ALEXANDRIA OCASIO CORTEZ, AND
HER TEAM IS IN HOT WATER
FOLLOWING THE DEPARTURE OF HER
CHIEF OF STAFF, JOINING IS NOW,
FORMING US WEST COAST NEWSROOM
WITH THE LATEST ON THE
BREAKING NEWS, CHIEF NEWS
CORRESPONDENT OUT THERE, AND
TRACE GALLAGHER.
BY THE WAY, HE WAS THE GUIDE IS
AT ALL THE GREEN NEW DEAL HAS
NOTHING TO DO WITH CLIMATE
CHANGE GRADE I WAS THE GUY.
TELL US ABOUT HIS PROBLEMS
TONIGHT.
>> HE'S WORKED ON THE GREEN NEW
DEAL BUT THE CONTROVERSIAL CHIEF
OF STAFF, FOR CONGRESSWOMAN
ALEXANDRIA OCASIO-CORTEZ, HE
SUDDENLY RESIGNED ON FRIDAY NOW
COME OUR CORPORATE COUSIN,
"THE NEW YORK POST," IS
REPORTING THAT HE IS BEING
INVESTIGATED BY FEDERAL
OFFICIALS FOR FUND-RAISING
VIOLATION.
THE FEDERAL ELECTION COMMISSION
SAID COMPLAINTS ONLY LEAD TO
INVESTIGATION IF THERE IS ENOUGH
EVIDENCE TO BACK THEM UP.
IN THIS CASE, THE ISSUE IS TO
POLITICAL ACTION COMMITTEES WERE
ATTACKED THAT HE STARTED TO
SUPPORT A PROGRESSIVE CANDIDATE.
THE ALLEGATION IS THAT MORE THAN
A MILLION DOLLARS WAS FUNNELED
FROM THE POLITICAL ACTION
COMMITTEE INTO TWO PRIVATE
COMPANIES THAT ARE CONTROLLED BY
TRUCKER VARDY.
OF COURSE, PACKS ARE SUBJECT TO
A VERY TIGHT RULES ON SPENDING
AND FUND-RAISING THAT PRIVATE
COMPANIES ARE NOT SUBJECT TO.
ALEXANDRIA OCASIO-CORTEZ DENIED
THERE WAS ANY WRONGDOING AND
SAYS THIS IS NOTHING MORE THAN
QUOTE, CONSERVATIVE INTEREST
GROUPS FILING BOGUS PROPOSALS.